we're asked to factor 35k squared plus
100k
minus 15. and because we have a non-zero
co or non-one coefficient out here the
best thing to do is probably by is
probably to factor this by grouping but
before we even do that let's see if
there's a common factor across all of
these terms and maybe we can get a one
coefficient out there if we can't get a
one coefficient we'll at least have a
lower coefficient here if we look at all
of these numbers they all look divisible
by five in fact they're all their
greatest common factor is five so let's
at least factor out a five so this is
equal to
five times 35 k squared divided by five
is seven
k squared a hundred k divided by five is
20k
20k and then negative 15 divided by 5 is
negative 3.
so we were able to factor out a 5 but we
still don't have a 1 coefficient here so
we're still going to have to factor by
grouping but at least the numbers here
are smaller so it'll be easier to think
about it in terms of finding numbers
whose product is equal to 7 times
negative 3 and whose sum is equal to 20.
so let's think about that let's figure
out two numbers that if i were to add
them or even better if i would take the
product
i get 7 times negative 3. 7 times
negative 3 is equal to 7
times negative 3 which is equal to
negative 21. and if i were to take their
sum if i add those two numbers
it needs to be equal to 20. it needs to
be equal to 20.
now once again because their product is
a negative number that means they have
to be of different signs so when you add
numbers of different signs you could
view it as you're taking the difference
of the positive version so the
difference between the positive versions
of the number has to be 20. so the
number that immediately jumps out is
we're probably going to be dealing with
20 and 21 and 1 will be the negative
because we want to get to a positive 20.
so let's think about it
so if we think of 20
and negative 1 their product is negative
21.
sorry if we take 20 21
21 and negative 1. their product is
negative 21 21 times negative 1 is
negative 21. and if you take their sum
21 plus negative 1 that is equal to 20.
so these
two numbers right there fit the bill now
let's break up this 20k right here into
a 21k and a negative 1k and a negative
1k so let's do that so let's rewrite the
whole thing
we have 5
times 7 k squared and i'm going to break
this 20k
i'm going to break that 20k into a let
me do it in this color right here i'm
going to break that 20k into a
plus 21k
minus k right that's or you could say
minus 1k if you want i'm using those two
factors to break it up and then we
finally have the minus 3 right there
now the whole point of doing that is so
that we can now factor each of each of
the two groups this could be our first
group
right here
and so what what can we factor out of
that group right there well both of
these are divisible by 7k so we can
write this as 7k
times 7k squared divided by 7k you're
just going to have a k left over
and then plus 21k divided by 7
k is just going to be a 3.
so that factors into that and then we
can look at this group right here
they have a common factor we can factor
out a negative one if we like so this is
equal to negative one
times k divided by negative one is k
negative three divided by negative one
is positive 3 and of course we have this
5 sitting out there
we have this 5 sitting out there the
whole time
now ignoring that 5 for a second you see
that both of these inside terms both of
these inside terms have k plus 3 is a
factor right let's have this k plus 3 is
a factor so we can factor that out so
let's ignore this 5 for a second this
inside part right here the stuff that's
inside the parentheses
we can factor k plus 3 out and it
becomes k plus 3
times
k plus 3 times
7 k
minus 1
minus 1 and if you don't if this seems a
little bizarre to you distribute the k
plus 3 onto this k plus 3 times 7 k is
that term k plus 3 times negative 1 is
that term and of course the whole time
you have that 5 sitting outside you have
that 5. we don't have to put parentheses
there just 5 times k plus 3 times seven
k minus one and we factored it we're
done